the fighting several donetsk isn't over
yet but russia now controls almost all
of the key eastern city
they have the momentum but the fighting
is as hard as it has been all conflict
and both sides are suffering massive
losses ukraine's deputy defense minister
has told sky news today that her country
is in dire need of more weapons
months of fighting is starting to take
its toll
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the white house is giving ukraine new
long-range missiles that can strike
russian forces deep behind their front
lines
there are reports the british will do
the same
there are now thousands and thousands of
unexploded mines and ordnance littering
fields and roads across ukraine
we watch as ukrainian soldiers carried
out controlled explosions on just a tiny
amount of those weapons
russia has occupied a vast area it could
take decades to make the country
completely safe
is going russia's way and ukraine needs
nato support to turn that around
the fall of several donetsk will be
russia's biggest victory yet
but putin wants to control the whole of
the donbass region at the very least
and they are still a long way from
achieving that
alastair bunker sky news in ukraine